et que alban bensa anthropologue
spécialiste de la nouvelle calédonie
bonsoir alban bensa merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors beaucoup
s'accordent à dire que contrairement au
précédent référendum l'atmosphère est
plus tendue cette année en nouvelle
calédonie est ce que c'est votre avis
est ce que le climat a changé
oui je pense que le climat a un petit
peu changé parce que le premier
référendum
ceux qui appellent à voter in on pensait
qu'ils allaient l'emporter largement
et ils ont eu la surprise de voir que
donc en mamie 56% des voix et les
indépendantistes 44% mais l'écart était
plus réduit que que prévu donc ceux qui
sont qui appelle à voter non
on est un peu alors que les
indépendantistes progressent encore
peut-être cette fois-ci ça c'est une des
raisons des détentions fin des tensions
de la montée de l'inquiétude de dix
entreprises à gérer
et puis la deuxième chose c'est que la
france semble perplexe d'apprendre
semble que l'état français s'en tient à
ce rôle d'arbitré qui exaspère les
français qui voudraient où les
calédoniens qui devrait la calédonie
reste purement française donc ils en
sont bien qu'il va falloir en quelque
sorte se mettent autour d'une table et
réfléchir ensemble pour trouver une
citoyenneté calédonienne et ce manque de
soutien de de la république française en
nouvelle calédonie est ce qui pourrait
faire basculer des électeurs qui
souhaitait toujours appartenir à la
république française et est ce qu'il y
aura qui pourrait basculer finalement
c'est possible nous disons qu'ils
pourraient plutôt fait venir
ollier pourrait s'abstenir faute d'un
d'un dialogue véritablement engagée est
ce que la crise
est ce que la crise sanitaire est ce que
vous m'entendez allemands eux mêmes ça
voilà est-ce que la crise sanitaire
on leur on le disait à la nouvelle
calédonie finalement très peu touchés
aujourd'hui pas du tout même par le
commis de 10,9 est ce que cette crise
sanitaire elle peut avoir un impact sur
le vote pourrait avoir un impact positif
le pôle pour tout le monde dans le sens
où les calédoniens peut dire nous nous
avons été joués le virus nous avons
repoussé les attaques du connacht
coronavirus par des mesures extrêmement
strictes prises d'ailleurs avant avant
l'état français dix jours avant et en
repoussant tout atterrissage tout avion
tout contact avec l'extérieur
donc ils administrent la preuve qu'au
compte n'applique de façon extrêmement
stricte des règles barrières et bien on
a pas de cas alors ce fait fait sur
l'histoire de la nouvelle calédonie
c'est une île il l'épidémie ont fait des
ravages dans vive au 19e siècle en
particulier auprès des kanak n'est pas
seulement
et donc les gens ont un souvenir amer de
ces délits ils veulent absolument pas
renouer avec je suis triste période
alors quels sont les arguments
aujourd'hui de chaque camp pourquoi les
indépendantistes veulent sortir de la
france et en finir avec la colonisation
pourquoi les non-indépendantistes
veulent y rester c'est pour le la
stabilité économique
alors les donneurs les
non-indépendantistes que le dirigent
fait parce qu'ils sont principalement
installées à nouméa et aussi un peu à
beaurains et parce qu'il unifie si
largement du de l'économie sous
perfusion qui a été installé en nouvelle
calédonie des droites défiscalisation et
surtout de l'argent français qui vient
compenser ou amant d'amendé ou abonder
dans le budget de la nouvelle calédonie
mais en même temps
c'est ignorer que la nouvelle calédonie
à ses propres ressources et notamment
dans le nord ou l'indépendance east gère
une usine de retraitement du nickel est
un massif de nickel alors les
indépendantistes eux s'appuient sur ce
succès s'appuie sur la l'amélioration
des conditions dit dans les endroits où
la petite d'habitude sauf quelques
poches de pauvreté ya justement en
province sud a noué un ou des anti
indépendantistes sont majoritaires mais
plus profondément
si vous voulez c'est un problème de
souveraineté est un problème c'est à
dire de pouvoir
lise indépendantiste une mouvance qui se
trouvent autour de calédoniens souhaite
réduire si pleinement le pouvoir sur la
terre calédonienne qu'ils considèrent
comme leur appartement dans
l'appartement et ne veulent plus
dépendre de la france dans des manières
dans des règlements des fiches
je ne veux découpage et la question
foncière question je visite les
questions sociales et ses comptines air
qui sont assez grands maintenant pour
voler de leurs propres ailes et il
inspire à une souveraineté une
souveraineté qui fera une souveraineté
dans une société plurielle adhérons
ligues différentes communautés
je trouverais leur place pour travailler
ensemble et que j'ai créé ensemble un
pouvoir indépendant sur les ressources
de la nouvelle-calédonie suffirait à
faire vivre toute toute la population
calédonienne
pour l'instant les ressources sont à
fait qu'amd du fait du nickel mais comme
vous le savez le cours du nickel est
lui-même tributaire de la situation
internationale avec des avec des hauts
et des bas et je pense qu'il faut pas se
voiler la face que s'il y avait une
indépendance de demain matin ici la
france ne continuaient pas afficher ce
processus de décolonisation aurait
certainement des difficultés tant que la
calédonie ne pourra pas développer
elle-même ses propres ressources pour
l'instant à 80% des produits sont
importés et ce qui importe ce sont
justement ceux qui aiment le plus
avec ces temps dans la france que comme
il dit parce qu'évidemment il y gagne
beaucoup à ce régime d'importation par
contre il y avait un régime plus fort de
développement de la pêche de
l'agriculture de l'informatique des
services et cetera la calédonie pourrait
comme tous les autres pays du pacifique
faut quand même noter être indépendante
dans des conditions certainement moins
vie réelle que celle nos ordis vous avez
des écarts de fortune chez domino née
d'une façon tout à fait honorable et
notamment en renforçant les liens ce qui
avait déjà été fait à l'époque de michel
rocard avec l'australie et la
nouvelle-zélande
pour conclure il ya une véritable unité
culturelle aujourd'hui entre les
habitants entre les calédoniens ya
peut-être pas une unité culturelle mais
il ya l'histoire des événements ni forts
vécus ensemble mémoire commune petit à
petit j'ai forgé notamment dans ses
trente années
la révision des manuels scolaires
la multiplication des spectacles
interculturel et malgré tout la
recherche de liens de liens anciens
entre les différentes communautés
ce qui fait que tout le monde est un peu
cousin de tout le monde et aujourd'hui
il ya des grands rassemblements
familiaux qui traverse les communautés
ethniques donc il ya un sentiment de
singularité calédonienne le très très
fort qui fait que la plupart des
calédoniens sur la plus longtemps
nouvelle qu'elle est nominée aujourd'hui
se sentent pas à l'aise lorsqu'ils
sortent de la nouvelle calédonie que ce
soit des kanaks où les noms kanak parce
que la calédonie existe comme un comme
un pays si vous voulez elle existe en
tant que tel avec des particularités
alimentaire relationnel vie codes
sociaux et une histoire qui a fait
beaucoup de progrès ces dernières années
c'est-à-dire la reconnaissance d'une
histoire commune des antiennes du pagne
de gentils
de la communication vivre les gens et
donc je pense qu'elle est chèrement en
tous les cas possibles d'une citoyenneté
calédonienne et pour défendre cette
citoyenneté calédonienne ouvrir un
dialogue qui fait qu'il ya de plus en
plus de de gens qui feraient prêt à
dialoguer mais encore faut-il que il ya
une volonté politique à la fois de la
part de l'état français pour favoriser
le dialogue et surtout de la part de
ceux qui y voient la maintient dans la
france sans confession très bien eh bien
écoutez
merci infiniment alban bensa pour votre
éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
anthropologue et spécialiste de la
nouvelle calédonie